on reproche aussi aux jeunes saccomano
et
il
très bien alors marche vers le mal sont
un jeune a fait le moins ch prend le
message et le garder pour mon sens alors
alors c'est la nation 1 2 3 de gens me
prennent pour un cinglé total et pas du
tout c'est une émission extraordinaire
que je ne rate jamais sur lci à la ville
bruisse rebelles avant je regarde je la
regarde pas c'est vrai que le des nerfs
de plus parce que si nous mére qu'est ce
qui t'a mis alors le tout et je savais
seulement que lui 1 parce qu'ils se
donnent à coeur joie
là c'était vraiment un grand connaisseur
qui connaissent tout mâtiné mission la
seule chose qu'on laissait quand on
essaie d'avoir une conversation avec ces
messieurs là c'est parler un peu du jeu
le football ce qui en somme ce qui est
plus intéressant pour un technicien
c'est d'essayer de d'avoir une discours
un langage quelque chose qui se rapporte
à ce que l'on fait ce que l'on essaie de
mettre en place tous les week-ends mais
ça les intéresse pas c'est eux c'est une
autre recherche est de savoir pourquoi
un tel ne joue pas pourquoi le président
ne fait pas ceci ou qui commande qui
dirige excès qui les intéresse c'est le
déballage systématique en fait j'adore
gênant c'est un ami de longue date bien
on se dire que nous sommes obligés de
signaler les carences de paris saint
germain ou d'autres clubs
quand il joue manon est une chose aussi
été très très bien chez eux c'est que
chacun de ses personnages
ils ont un club qu'ils ont à auxquels
ils sont très attachés éventuellement
bondoux ne fonctionne pas alors là
s'inquiète pas et vont essayer ça va
être très très court si par exemple un
marche bien on va parler qu'une minute
si ça marche mal on va parler pendant 15
minutes zahia mais sur les autres on est
un peu plus gentil non c'est vrai que
paris saint germain l'olympique de
marseille attire l'attention du public
on n'y peut rien donc il faut donner ce
que le public demande
on va pas parler et ils sont bons
sympathique et tout ça éternellement de
sedan 2-3 et de toutes ces équipes
éminemment sympathique est bonne et
pourtant nous mais il sait sur le public
saint germain public aime l'olympique de
marseille en tant que je sais pas des
choses en les orientant les deux
ensemble il faut alors se khimik gènes
ont revu le match comme ça toute la
journée
vous l'avez trouvé en amérique du sud
c'est vraiment non le temps des
reportages je les trouvais en amérique
du sud ça c'est vrai mais ça c'est
plutôt bien
les reportages de match là le côté
polémique
je n'ai plus tôt trouvait en italie en
italie où il ya une émission très
célèbre qui s'appelle il pro che sûr de
l'inédit dirigée par un homme et
biscuits hardy et c'est un peu on refait
le match
j'ai bossé durant les procédures de
procès du lundi n'est d'ailleurs si en
singeant jeunes saccomano georges
briquet grand grand grand commentateur
sportif des années 50 au lycée daudet à
nîmes que vous avez trouvé votre voix on
peut rien si je vous dit tout sait on
avait un professeur de mathématiques qui
était sourd les sourds comme c'est pas
possible
et le gros gag le gag est essentielle
c'était d'aller le voir et le dire je
parlais baisser votre femme s'il vous
plaît et il disait toujours attendait y
en a vous irez et c'est pour dire l'état
de sa surdité et quand on s'est aperçu
très rapidement qu'il était sourde à ce
point moi je me suis mis à faire dans la
classe des reportages de match et voilà
et je suis comme ça que ça a démarré
détruit votre voix vous y trouver votre
voie ainsi ensuite les le provençal il
ya eu europe il ya eu rtl lci et cetera
et à part ça je tiens quand même à
signaler au passage qu' il vous arrive
de donner dans la littérature la vraie
avec notamment un excellent roman qui
est paru en 1999 qui s'appelle goncourt
32 et qui raconte l'histoire d'un a
nommé guy mazeline qui est le goncourt
en 1932 contre céline séance
extraordinaire le mec il a été écrasé
par son concurrent et aujourd'hui on ne
parle de mazine que parce que vous avez
facebook a sinon on parle beaucoup plus
de céline effectivement alors mercredi
soir à bastia
alors mercredi soir vers pas encore joué
par le césar tout de suite dès le coup
d'envoi alors que il avait ce jour
j'allais jouer un petit peu contre
strasbourg c'est déjà y avait déjà
repris depuis quelques temps c'est un
choix c'est un choix de peut-être par
rapport à une certaine animation de jeu
où on a besoin d'un arrière sont comme
par l'eau dans le dans l'entrejeu et
cette fête ses 22 ans elle n'est pas
joué depuis le 1er décembre quoi pedro
parce que si je les fait venir c'est
qu'il ya un intérêt c'est un garçon qui
est gaucher qui peut prendre ce côté
gauche qui est intéressant c'est à dire
ce qui peut nous apporter beaucoup
vous regrettez pas là non plus que
jamais de cette année avec mes idées way
et the way qui sont allés au bout de
leurs idées lancé le maire
méfie toi ça fait dix ans que j'y suis
et bon alors ça va ça avec des hauts des
bas on se maintient ce que je vois c'est
que ronaldinho pourquoi il est resté si
longtemps sur le banc la tête eu mal aux
dents et ait entraîné là c'est l'asn
il a fallu mettre en place une
préparation spécifique individuel pour
lui pour essayer de lui faire retrouver
son niveau son niveau qui était celui de
la saison dernière celui qui nous a fait
gagner des matchs lui qui est par sa
qualité sa sa technique peut encore et
je pense qu'il va revenir parce qu'il
est en train de faire des efforts il va
redevenir ce qu'il était c'est une
discussion mondial j'ai vu au zapping
des jeunes d'irakiens qui discutaient
entre eux du rôle de ronaldinho au psg
la chance de le voir jouer avant parce
qu'il ne fait pas souvent jouer mais
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire
pourquoi il fait pas plus jouer
ronaldinho jeunes fernandez luis
fernandez de ceux ci ronaldinho est un
garçon qui n'est pas toujours tellement
sérieux qui a expliqué qu'après nous
manque encore 2
les conditions physiques etc c'est sur
ça que je jugeais or c'est sur ce que je
vois durant la veillée
la seule chose c'est que moi je le juge
sur ce que je le vois à l'entraînement
sur le retard qu'il a et puis je crois
qu'il va redevenir qu'il va refaire les
efforts des petits bouts de matches
comme ça progressivement et là par
exemple depuis le début du mois j'ai
envie de janvier je crois qu'au total il
a dû le faire jouer neuf minutes
non c'est pas vrai jouer jouer 112
minutes où je crois on a dit non
mais pedro qui lui n'avait joué que 9
minutes c'est la trêve depuis lens
louise la ligne et tout le match mais
envoie il n'était pas bastia il a dit la
ligne est tout le mal qu'il est arrivé
j'ai sorti à la 50e minute et ronde
alors tu lis pas les gens
ce brave ronaldinho kaka a fracassé un
joueur bastiais d'une façon épouvantable
et il me restait totalement son quart 11
ça c'est vrai expulsé injustement je
trouve que c'est plutôt un tuto sur se
défend plutôt qu'autre chose on va
arrêter de mettre en cause des décisions
des arbitres franchement je crois que ce
sera plus être les arbitres ils font
très bien leur travail
il a été blanchi vous savez c'est l'été
non si je dis absolument vous allez
traiter une arbitre d'handicapés bal de
ce côté-là chuteront qui n'est que je
n'ai pas dit alors il ya eu un carton
aussi pour cristobal et ce qui fait que
le psg aujourd'hui - recorman d'un truc
c'est le nombre des cartons rouges
elle est pas mal de ce côté-là rays
carton rouge depuis le début de la
saison on est leader à mêmes on a treize
13 14
donc avec un surcoût de france j'ai
commis deux autres en coupe de lieux
passe elle de cartons qui suit bien le
champion du monde des cartons rouges
devaient l'amener cieux
ouais bon alors luis ont sérieusement
effectivement vous avez été blanchi par
la commission de discipline jeudi
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même un
problème avec l'arbitrage là c'était
nelly viennot que vous aviez traité
d'handicapés lance également ça s'est
produit il ya une discussion sur une sur
une action et puis la seconde année on a
eu avec des lits
vous avez fait part d'une position nous
a fait une demande pour un enfant qui
était qui avait un problème et on avait
on avait reçu l'enfant et l'enfant est
décédé trois semaines après je prends ça
comme elle s'occupe d'une association on
pensait qu'il souffrait d'une
association
il y avait répondu favorablement et
c'est pour ça que quand on les dix ans
sur le banc et enlacé avec l'association
des handicapés
attention les lire on a été gentils
quand même si on n'a pas à employer un
terme pour essayer de lui faire du mal
fernandez avec ses yeux bleus il te
raconte les structures je comprends qu
elle juge aujourd'hui si je disais mais
les bulles et nelly commission l'a jugé
et tu connaissais mal à mme marchal
cependant d'imaginer nourrissent quand
il était au magazine piqué une mobylette
et que vous ayez encore will et moi si
vous leur parlez comme ça je comprends
c'est au travers des mailles oui dans le
genre par les marchés il a fallu écrire
sur les fraudeurs la porte du vestiaire
père m'a tuer il ya un autre truc un peu
plus grave c'est vrai qu'une fois vous
avez failli écraser enfin compte le mur
dans un parking un arbitre or ça c'était
et une enquête là-dessus et j'étais
aussi blanchi une tendance à me chercher
ou actuellement c'est normal qu'ils
essaient qui est passionné qui a sa
paris saint germain hier fernandez et
ronaldinho oui alors les deux stars
mondiales ans il joue et l'autre 20 qui
joue c'est fernandez qui joue là tu n'es
tu veux pas dire que je peux pas
supporter dans la nuit parce que c'est
quand même un garçon qu'on a repris la
saison d'année avec eux et qu'il a quand
même été au championnat du monde il
était champion du monde
suite au travail qu'on a réussi avec lui
quand même c'était que l'ajout des qui
jouent alors tu peux pas dire que je ne
porte pas au contraire on aimerait le
retrouver comme il était la saison
d'années à faire
quel est l'entraîneur qui va se priver
d'un champion du monde tu le connais toi
celui-là c'est peut-être peut-être ttc
grand numéro 2
regardez vous pourrez pas mon maire et
jean louis mahalla
c'est vrai et highlander moi je n'ai
jamais commencé à chauffer la faim dans
les temps
alors il ya un truc c'est vrai que l'on
est exclu du banc de touche luis vous
diriger le match avec un petit portable
comme ça de plus loin et très très haut
et c'est vrai est insupportable c'est
dur à vivre un mois j'ai besoin d'être
seul sur le bord du terrain vous avez
quoi des jumelles un écran de télé comme
en fait non de de la haute voltige
une fois le match c'est qu'on en
angleterre les managers semaine dans la
tribune en point mi temps est bon et
ferguson décembre deuxième étant sur le
banc bord du doigt parce qu'ils ont
l'impression de mieux voir le départ
d'un match et mieux voir et d'analyser
des sorties en grand le placement de
l'équipe s'il est bien placé et ensuite
de rectifier à la mi temps
bon moi j'aime y être tout de suite être
leur bord du terrain comment ça va avec
laurent perpère ça va bien eh bien oui
mais pas de problème de ce côté-là ça
donne que j'apprécie bien le match qui
s'en va et en même temps alors pour
réveillonner ray bas parce que
maintenant c'est devant du tout ça là
ces médecins par l'impact se dit alors
ah ouais bah c est ce qui pourrait me
dire à moi le dernier gène vous prévoyez
quoi comme classement pau psg c'est
tellement dans les trois premiers noms
n'ont cette fois pas je crois pas mais
il pas viguier et peuvent y arriver
parce que dans la dernière émission où
l'un de mes camarades dans ce petit
théâtre donc a dit ceci qui était très
intéressant aider l'équipe de luis elle
ressemble finalement à celle d'arthur
georges dao début des années 90 c'est à
dire que les soldats sont là peuvent
être là mais on s'emmerde terriblement
un coup 2e il va peut-être faire la
ligue des champions mais n'empêche que
c'est assez triste c'est que tu es un
grand connaisseur de football parce que
je respecte énormément ce que tu as
avait beaucoup de matches je vois et oui
mais c'est ça c'est que j'ai joué à la
première gambardella
tu étais dans la trémie toute première
gambardella la toute première 1954 c'est
ce que ces événements je connais rien en
fait les humeurs l'a confirmé je ne sais
pas de quoi vous parlez
justement on va profite